we are unfortunately as i've mentioned
getting to the point in the vaccination
campaign here in the united states
where supply is exceeding demand
increasingly by more and more now on the
bonus show today
we are going to talk about the
forthcoming approval of at least the
pfizer vaccine for ages 12 to 15
fives are already approved 16 plus that
should happen
could be within a week i mean imminently
and that will
add a whole bunch of people to
eligibility
and hopefully we will continue getting
people vaccinated but we are getting to
a point
where the anti-vaccine movement has been
i don't want to call it successful
because it almost sounds like praise but
it has been
uh effectively destructive
in terms of getting enough people to say
i don't know that i need the vaccine at
all or i don't know that i need it right
now
that joe biden has had to announce a
completely new
strategy yesterday joe biden hoping for
normalcy to some degree by the fourth of
july holiday in the united states
that is certainly in question as
vaccination continues to slow down
so there has been an overhaul to the
pandemic and joe biden
to the vaccination program and joe biden
announcing yesterday
that this is a new phase the goal is to
at least
partially vaccinate meaning at least the
first shot
for 70 of adults by july 4th
and this is you know we talked it wasn't
a major criticism but we
acknowledged that when joe biden was
about to take office and said i want to
vaccinate 100 million within 100 days
we said that's not really ambitious
because we're
well on track for that and then joe
biden said well let's do 200 million in
the first hundred days
and it ended up being about 220 million
i believe shots in the first hundred
days
this is actually ambitious now to say 70
percent
at least one shot by july 4th because
it's continuing to slow down
at first remember we had supply issues
we had distribution problems
that has all been resolved and now the
issue is just telling people hey you
know
if you don't want to wear masks if you
don't want to have
capacity limits if you don't want to
have to think about are my kids going to
be in school or not
just go ahead and get yourselves
vaccinated and those most eager to get
vaccinated have done it as many of you
know i had my second shot in late
february
and was considered fully vaccinated by
around you know the first 10 days of
march or something like that
i was extremely eager most people in my
circles are
actually every i can't think of anyone i
know that's not getting vaccinated
personally
um and now that has changed and so we
need to figure out
something that can be done part of this
is going to be making it easier for
people to get vaccinated
not only at the beginning remember you
had to find an appointment
and they were difficult to come by and
they were often not conveniently located
a lot of those appointment
appointment-based vaccination clinics
have gone to
just show up but still it's not
convenient enough for some people so
now the goal of the biden administration
is for tens of thousands of pharmacies
to not only start doing vaccinations if
they're not
many cvs and walgreens already are but
to just be set up for walk-in
just just show up and get vaccinated
that is the degree to which
supply is now exceeding demand in the
united states
a very different problem than much of
the world much of the world
still has not just supply issues much of
the world has
no supply and we have a
a great situation in terms of supply in
the united states and tons of people are
like
nah i don't know and we've seen
anti-vac stuff and vaccine skeptical
stuff from tucker carlson we've seen it
we talked last week about joe rogan's
comments about young people uh not
not needing to get vaccinated if they
are healthy and talking about
you know if you're working out although
there's no connection whatsoever between
working out and how likely it is that
you will get
the virus and be able to spread it um so
this is the new plan
walk in any time at tens of thousands of
pharmacies
we will see if the pharmacies go with it
joe biden also announcing a new federal
website as well as a phone number
uh where you can just call or log on put
in your address your location it'll tell
you what's the closest site
and unfortunately we are at the point
where if it's not really really easy for
people a lot of people just won't do it
so let's hope for
an increase to vaccination numbers those
have declined
as of yesterday more than 106 million
people are what we would call
fully vaccinated um and more than 56
of adults about 148 million have
received at least one dose which
by itself provides a significant level
of protection
but not as much as getting both doses so
let's hope for an
increase i think that listen i remain
optimistic
because as opportunities to do things if
you're vaccinated continue to
open um that is going to push more
people to get vaccinated
as um we continue seeing
easier and easier availability i think
we're going to get there and i think we
will beat the variance although
without a doubt at some point a booster
uh tweaked to the variants will be
necessary
but it's a question of well we could
have been looking really really good in
june
versus maybe it's not going to be until
july versus maybe it'll be august or
maybe it will be september
so increasingly opportunities to get
vaccinated but the trump
the the trump administration handing off
significant vaccine skeptical sentiment
to the biden administration
when you say for a year this thing's not
very serious
that makes a lot of people believe they
don't really need a vaccine and that's
exactly what we're dealing with now
tell me if you are seeing anti-vac
sentiment
in your community find me on twitter
deepakman we'll take a quick break and
be right back
one of our sponsors today is strategic
voters a new podcast that features
election experts political campaign
strategists and everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s
political landscape on the activism side
strategic voters as an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one
party down the ballot if you want to
hear some really different
and interesting opinions and approaches
to voting and viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen
the latest two episodes feature rachel
cobb and lana atkinson as guests i've
been listening to it myself
i've been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and independent which i love
find the strategic voters podcast on all
major podcast platforms and make sure to
follow them
on twitter at strategic voters